so yes I thought that after lunch a
great thing to do would be a detailed
analysis of Wagner's Ring cycle so it's
this this is what we're about to do no
not at all and so I promise you that
this talk is not going to be as as
intense and as heavy hopefully we'll be
a bit lighter although I will touch on
some I think important subjects but
hopefully it'll be a bit a bit a good
after lunch conference hopefully so um
when I want to talk about it I want to
talk about the problem of culture and
the problem of art I am an artist I'm an
icon Carver I I ended up adding some of
my carvings into the presentation this
morning because yesterday a lot of
people were telling me oh I'd like to
see your carving so we'll see you'll see
some of my carvings in the in the
presentation there are a few artists
here as well today and I want to talk
about what how is there going to be how
is it possible for their for culture to
move forward how is it possible for art
to move forward considering our
situation right now so in in the 19th
century vogner came up with this term
the gazhams comes back this notion of
the total work of art right the the
perfect work of art and it's in that
notion in that idea of a total work of
art that he developed his Ring cycle of
operas and his idea was to create a work
of art which would join together all the
different arts into one thing and so he
thought that the Opera was the perfect
place to do that to take narrative to
take music have dance have also visual
representation in terms of composition
all of that pull together into one
massive total artwork we have
a lot of people have said that in fact
the the the real let's say kazama-kun
spark is the movie the the the movie
does exactly that it pulls together you
know these narratives and it has you
know like a an expensive good movie has
this amazing soundtrack which actually
follows the narrative structure they
have a science like a musical science of
following narrative structure using
music and there's also the composition
of the screen you know that there's
color all of that comes together into
the this this example of the perfect
let's say so I chose two images one of a
higher high end more you know artsy
movie and one which is the recent
popular end game movie which was I saw
which was absolutely visually astounding
it's astounding what they what they can
do and in terms of narrative also
pulling in all these stories dealing
with myth using mythological structures
it's pretty amazing what they're able to
come together and as we look forward
obviously we are looking towards a
possibility of having absolute total
immersive you know narrative with all of
that story everything we could have this
immersive complete experience of
vogner's kazama-kun spark this total
artwork coming into our field of vision
and so you would think right and then
III just for father Steven I added that
this this morning there's a holodeck
from Star Trek which is the the ultimate
in that imaginable possible perfect you
know cultural experience would be in the
holodeck but you would think right so
you would think that imagine a culture
that has come to create such perfection
that has come to create these these
works of narrative structure that are
that cost millions and hundreds of
millions of dollars to to make and are
gonna bring about you know hundreds of
millions of people to come see them you
would think that you would think wow
they
if we've reached that level of cultural
manifestation we definitely should have
a pretty beautiful cohesive society
right turns out that is not the case
turns out in fact that it is not and as
most of us have seen in the past few
years we have noticed in fact the very
contrary as we watch the social fabric
in Western Europe in North America as we
watch it start to fray and start to
dissolve and we're seeing things we
haven't seen since the 1930s people
fighting in the streets the signs are
not are not good in terms of where our
culture is leading us so what's the
problem what's the problem why is our
culture which is so refined and you
don't have to go watch the Marvel movie
you can go see have an extremely elitist
opera an extremely elitist concert all
of these things you can go to you we
have more culture available to us than
any time in all the history of the
entire world you know you could see any
show you want anything you want you
could you could probably find a place
and you could go see it you go to
Broadway and there are tons of shows you
there are tons of museums tons of so
what why is it that we are there right
one of the problems there is many one of
the problems is the problem of
entertainment we have come to a point
where we have confused culture and
entertainment we think that culture is
to go somewhere and sit and have an
aesthetic experience and there's a
there's a book a wonderful book called
amusing ourselves to death some of you
maybe have have read it by Neil postman
and he says when a population becomes
distracted by trivia
when cultural life is redefined as a
perpetual round of entertainments when
serious public conversation becomes a
form of baby talk when in short a people
become an audience and their public
business a vaudeville act then a nation
finds itself at risk culture death is a
clear possibility yeah
and social media is the ultimate version
of this because and I say that I am on
social media right father Steven we're
all on social media we're all using
social media but social media has
tricked us in believing in relationships
which are not relationships which are
performance and consumption that's what
we're doing on social media we are
posting things and people are
voyeuristically watching them and I
don't even know who's watching my who's
interacting with my stories on social
media it we have turned our
relationships into into performances and
into audiences that is how our
relationships have been have been
transformed into by this problem of
culture traditional culture traditional
art in every single traditional culture
in the world including you know Western
medieval culture including Eastern
Orthodox culture culture is
participative culture is not culture the
ultimate act of culture or the arts are
not spectacles are not only spectacles
but we that's all we have left of
culture right museums are places where
things go to die
that's what museums are they are giant
cemeteries for objects where we have
removed objects from their actual use
and we have put them up to gaze at and
I'm not saying that there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing essentially wrong
with looking at the pass in order to
learn from the past but when that's all
that's left of your culture you know
it's all that's left of your culture is
this you know the these spaces of
performance and these spaces of of
showing objects that are ripped from
their context and we think that that's
that's lively we think that that's
culture then we're in serious prog we
have a serious problem one of the one of
the issues that has come as we see
happen in culture I mean starting even I
would say at the Renaissance we start to
see what you could call Adi incarnation
we start to see things start to rip to
pull apart okay we start to see this
notion of high art start to rise up and
then we start to see this notion of
objects production let's say or objects
for you start to come down so we
separate this notion that we have these
objects of cultural contemplation and
then we have these objects of pure use
and there's no connection between the
two
we don't conceive that there's art in
those objects and we don't concede that
there's use in the high art objects we
have come to somehow glorify the fact
that these useless objects these useless
events that don't have purpose in our
society that don't have relevance that
aren't there to bring us together like a
folk dance or like a a festival and is
in a village that we have we have
convinced ourselves that that is in fact
the highest form of culture now the word
art in in in the medieval world means
fitting together properly
that's what refers to and
so the the notion of art we still have
that expression today right we still
have this expression where we talk about
the art of something that's how the
medievals understood art there was the
art of rhetoric there was the art of
painting the art of woodworking and
there were these and so art was not we
didn't have this idea of making art
nobody ever made art people used art to
make things and those things were had
purposes so the the very notion what we
call art works is a is a very disturbing
perversion of the traditional idea of
art because what we what we've been
convinced is that somehow art has a
value in itself that these objects
because until you have these arguments
everybody's heard these arguments see
this painting and they're like is this
art is this not art what's art is this
art is this annnddd and it's been
lasting for 100 years since the
beginning of the century arguing about
what is art and what is not art and the
answer is that it doesn't matter doesn't
matter right those objects don't have
value because they are art their value
should be based on what they're doing in
the world not whether or not their art
but I mean we're kind of so far from
that right now it's very difficult to
come back anyway so here is this notion
of the high art and the design and we've
come now we really I mean it's very
extreme we have all these objects in our
houses that we don't even think about
they're just there for our use they're
just there for us to to consume and part
of it is of course technical
technological advancement of course it's
part of why we are able to think that a
fork doesn't matter because you can get
it for cheap at Walmart you know in a
time when an artisan would make your
fork and that was his let's say that was
his vocation the relationship to what
you would receive was very different
then then the mass-produced object
all right so here we see the the
medieval arts alright and so this is the
alright these are the traditional
cultural events right traditional
culture events were and are those that
still exist there are a few that still
exist are participative you know and of
course well get to it of course the
church is one of the last vestiges of
places where people come together and
participate in a cultural event which is
not just to be cultural but is actually
serving the purpose of uniting the
community together facing i transcendent
God you know so it brings people
together but it also is there to kind of
show us where we should be looking at so
there's an interesting
there's an interesting thinker from the
beginning of the century i really i
really suggest that people read his book
he's actually not a christian he's a
he's a single e's man his name is ananda
coomaraswamy and he was the curator of
the boston museum for many years and he
sometimes you need someone from the
outside coming from pretty culture that
still is somewhat traditional to see the
monstrosity of your own of your own
culture and and coomaraswamy really
defended this real notion of art so he
said art is not tangible we cannot call
a painting art as the word artifact or
artificial imply the thing made is a
work of art made by art but is not
itself art the art remains in the artist
and is the knowledge by which things are
made so art is the human capacity to
make things the human capacity to create
in a way you could say that we still
have the word craft we still use that
word in its right
sense that is it is the skill that the
artist has and then applies to the world
and so like I said it removes this this
immediate value of the object that is
being made just because it's it's art it
doesn't matter the question is what is
it what is the object what is it doing
and so one of the thinkers I think
especially for us artists one of the
thinkers that has helped to reawaken the
possibility of traditional art because
we see I mean I see because I came
through the contemporary art world and
several people I don't know Heather if
you did Heather came through the
contemporary art world several of the
professional iconographer you'll meet in
North America actually started out as
contemporary painters contemporary
installation artists we studied the
contemporary art and we came to the end
of that we we realized that it was
running out of steam and that the
question we needed to ask was too big
for the art system to answer the
question wasn't what should I make this
or that kind of art should I make this
or that kind of painting should I make
this or that kind of sculpture the
question became what is the value of
these objects in what is the whole value
of your project the entire project of
Contemporary Art what's its purpose in
the world so it became very difficult
for us to remain in that contemporary
art world because the question is too
big they can't answer it I'm not asking
you I'm not asking you to interpret the
paintings and to tell me what the
paintings I'm asking you why does this
painting exist like what what what is it
doing in the world what's what what
justifies its it's taking up space in
the world right and the answer ended up
a lot of the answer ended up secretly
being something about prestige and
something about financial transactions
and investment and all that there's a
lot of that that was happening
in terms of understanding what the true
value of contemporary art ended
being and so one of the thinkers that I
think has helped us is is Heidegger
Heidegger has read a few books one is
called the origin of the work of art but
another one of his books that people
don't think of in terms of art is is the
the book called the question concerning
technology because the word the Greek
word for art for the Latin word art the
the best translation of it is techn a
craft we still have that word we use it
in technology the problem is that we've
like I said we've ripped everything
apart where we now have this notion of
art that's up here and is esoteric and
and intellectual and then we have techn
a which is down here which is making
objects for consumption but in the
ancient vision that's not how how it was
understood and so Heidegger interprets
Aristotle and Aristotle considered
technique to be a form of truth to be a
form of unveiling right I don't know how
to pronounce this word a lúthien lúthien
or luthier Alethea anyways truth or
unveiling so this is Heidegger
interpreting Aristotle so techne is a
form of a lúthien unveiling or truth
whoever builds a house or a ship or
forward to the sacrificial chalice
reveals what is brought forth this
revealing gathers together making that
gesture for you on purpose because I did
it all morning gathers together in
advance the aspect and the matter of the
ship or house with the view to the
finished thing and vision envisioned as
completed thus what is decisive in
technique does not lie in the making and
manipulating of means but rather in this
Afra mentioned revealing right it is as
revealing not as manufacturing that
Tecna is a bringing forth so if you
think about what I talked about this
morning he is dealing with this question
he's realizing that making something is
gathering things gathering objects
gathering ideas gathering all this to
together bringing it into something
which reveals the being of that thing so
if I'm making a cup I am gathering
elements bringing them together in order
to reveal to you the function the
purpose the the reality of this cup so
you get a whole other a whole other
vision of what it means for a human
being to make right you get that sense
of this participative act that to make
something is almost it's almost as it's
almost a an act of let's say lower
creation right it's almost the
possibility of to the extent that we're
capable of to participate in creation to
be that that image of God but in order
for it to be that things have to
actually come together and one of those
things is and the most one of the most
important things is purpose and so it's
not it's not arbitrary that we have
removed purpose from our culture that we
have removed the reasons for things in
our cultural events we have reduced them
to distraction talked about distraction
this morning we have reduced them to
distraction to entertainment and so they
are spinning on the outside of that
wheel right and we've lost that which
brings it together
and with as a strange thing happening as
well very strange thing because it's not
only that we're dispersing out into this
kind of fragmented chaos but actually
think we're actually seeing things right
now seeing them flip upside down it's
very fascinating to watch because the
last remnant of participative culture in
our and in our world was Church so he
was the last thing left there was still
people who went to church sat you know
stood together sang together even a even
a Protestant Church you know you were
still at least doing something right
you're it's music it's narrative its
words and we're together and we're all
doing it together it's bringing us
together focused on something which is
beyond us but it's very strange to watch
today right when you vote we've all seen
it happen we've all seen Church turned
into entertainment and and and and
churches are doing everything they can
to become as close to entertainment as
they possibly can light shows it's a
concert people don't know the words of
the songs anymore because you'll have to
change songs every two weeks because you
always have to innovate you have to keep
people on the edge you have to surprise
them surprise as part of entertainment
you know the titillation of the new is
is a part of the entertainment every
time someone asks me about icons and and
and asks about you know why you know we
should enter we should innovate in icons
and it's like hmm well I'm not against
innovation per se but I do struggle with
your desire to innovate though like I do
struggle with a little bit of that we
have a name for that in the Orthodox
tradition it's called a Cydia it's a
passion this this incapacity to this
desire this in stable feeling we have to
always have something new have something
changing to kind of keep us feeling
alive you know and everybody's felt that
did boredom you know you want you you
want to be entertained and so that
obviously is one of the strange events
but the other strange event is we're
seeing the opposite happen as well we're
watching entertainment culture become
liturgical and that is the weirdest of
all so everybody knows about cosplay
right so people will get make costumes
of their favorite fictional characters
will dress up and then we'll get
together and we'll kind of reenact these
things will will will will celebrate
their fictional characters and it's a
fascinating thing to watch because it is
born it's born out of that same desire
we have the desire that should be the
desire for for liturgy the desire to
come together and to act as one and to
to to to act together that is now
flipping into these strange venues there
is a monastery near in my house about 10
minutes away from my house and like all
monasteries in Quebec all the Catholic
churches all the monasteries that
they're all dying everybody's going away
and they don't know what to do with
these buildings right what we have all
these buildings the most Catholic place
in the world it used to be so now we
have all these buildings what do we do
and so this monastery they've been
struggling with it trying to find a
venue and finally they were able to sell
it and everybody's celebrating because
they were able to sell the monastery and
and and it was bought by a an
intrapreneur someone who organizes
events and so what he's gonna do is he's
going to have Harry Potter events in the
church so the church they'll have people
dressed up as the students in Harry
Potter and then they'll reenact scenes
from the Harry Potter movies and books
in the church because beautiful right
beautiful architecture and he's going to
do Game of Thrones events where people
are gonna come and reenact Game of
Thrones and and and all of that so and
this is not a joke there is an
organization it's called Harry Potter
and the sacred texts and they have
churches they don't call them churches
but they have groups that meet every
week and they have these liturgical
readings of the Harry Potter books they
gather together and they they all over
the United States they sit together
and they they they try to participate in
the story of Harry Potter they have this
desire to participate this desire to to
to for something to be to not they want
their entertainment to not just be
entertainment because they have felt the
emptiness of that and so they want to
enter into the story they want to
participate and the ultimate example now
is this last movie who's seen the
spider-man movie rave all you guys are
too Christian for me no one has seen
this good it's going on what is going on
so so then this last spider-man movie it
was called spider-man into the spider
verse and in this movie the main
character discovers lawrence to be
spider-man by reading spider-man comic
books by interacting with another like
the original spider-man so he is being
initiated into the spider-man world he's
this he's a spider-man catechumen you
know and so it's not just that we have
spider-man but now we have the story of
spider-man we're in the story there's a
character who is learning from
spider-man to become spider-man right
and and the whole movie keeps saying
anybody can wear the mask anybody can
become spider-man which is obviously
really stupid because not most of you
don't can't stick to walls I think I I
don't I don't unless unless if you have
enough faith in spider-man maybe you can
stick to walls I don't know I'm not sure
but this mean but but the desire right
the desire is so real this desire to
participate is is you can't blame them
you cannot blame people for having this
desire to enter into the story to to be
part of the story and so that's so the
title of my talk was liturgical art is
the only solution for the cultural
problem
and I think that statement is true in
every single context whether or not
people return to Christianity and
discover the liturgical life or whether
they stay with spider-man or Harry
Potter liturgical art is the only
solution to the cultural problem people
are looking to identify to participate
and they they're there at the end of
this bland you know outside
entertainment mode because it it leaves
you empty but of course I will you know
of course I have made my decision I've
made my choice which side I want to go
and I and so I would I want to do for
the last part of my talk is I want to
try to explain why liturgy is the only
game on Scoones VII the only total
artwork and so what I mean by liturgy
now is you have to see it as a little
bit bigger than just the let's say the
actual ritual or the actual prayer the
actual services now what I'm talking
about
liturgy and liturgical experience or
liturgical art encompasses the of course
the services the the the constant
services which exist actually you know
that we I have a small part of but in
the monastic world exist to their
fullness and there's this totality of
filling up time with prayer right you
can see that as the ultimate version of
it and we participate in it you know at
different levels but it also includes of
course the architecture of the church it
also includes the iconography of the
church it includes of course the music
itself not just the service but the
actual music it also includes the
objects that are made to participate the
vestments the vessels
you know the furniture all of this is
what I mean by liturgical the liturgical
full liturgical experience you could say
and it not only includes that but it
also includes the very
cycle of the liturgical year which means
that the Terkel year is this entering
into the story of Christ which follows
the whole year right we enter into the
story of the mother of God and into the
story of Christ and that's the basic
track of the of the year and so what
happens is we see this is where we see
everything come together right so vogner
said talked about narrative talked about
music talked about the visual aspect
that's a visual art so we add to that
architecture you know and then we
finally add the ultimate one which is
participation right and so the
liturgical year is the true cultural
manifestation why because it brings us
together it creates a qualifies time it
gives meaning to time and we all know
that we it's fun it's great now today
it's actually great today because we're
so far from that we're so far from the
liturgical time that we can easily point
to everybody and say right now in our
world is they're qualified time what's
the difference between day and the night
it's barely gone it's barely gone
between day and nights barely gone
between the days of the week pretty much
gone you know the stores are open 24
hours and they're always there and we
said so time is just this strangely
spread you know quantity across and we
don't have this rhythm that is found in
the traditional cultures this rhythm
which marks time and and which which is
like music you can imagine the
liturgical year as a giant the giant
Orchestra you know as a giant opera
which lasts the entire year which
follows this story of Christ and you can
enter into this story
and also like I said in Marc's time I
have said this several times in other
talks but you know in a medieval village
where do you put the church in the
middle right you put the church in the
middle of the city and then everybody
sees this the spire of the church
it becomes the the center of the village
it becomes the place where everybody
meets it becomes the reference of the
village and so all of this is qualifying
time it's giving us the reason why we
even exist as units we don't even know
like what's the difference between this
suburb in that suburb we don't know we
don't even know why there's a limit
between the two just a bunch of houses
spread over the terrain like that but a
few malls we don't have town centers
anymore we don't have anything which
qualifies space it's gone right and even
though even the the shopping malls are
on their way out soon there won't even
be shopping malls those are the last
remainders of a place of communion you
could say in in in space those are going
away all that is left are individual
segregated habitations with people who
don't know barely know their neighbor
and who are connected with all these
other people and who are performing for
all these strangers online and so the
church the the the the church qualifies
space and then it also gathers material
culture it creates the standard for
architecture the standard for for space
he creates the standard for fabrication
and usually having the most beautiful
objects it becomes the standard for
other objects you can see that as a
hierarchy you know like the King's
chapel or the the patriarchs Church has
the most beautiful things and as you go
down the hierarchy you have more simple
things but are all looking towards those
those patterns let's say and so it
qualifies even the fabrication of things
I had to put this in for father Stephen
and so that is why I think those of us
that have left the contemporary art
world and entered into this
participative art it is amazing it is
it's hard it's so hard because when I
meet artists they don't understand like
contemporary artists like you make what
you make religious pictures for churches
really ok and then they think that I'm
doing it kind of by default because I
couldn't make it you know as an artist
that's what they think that's do they
think it's hilarious but they don't
understand the joy because when I make
when I make an icon so I'm gonna start
showing you some of my icons as I as I
go through this way so when I make an
icon I am engaging in the language of
the church so like a poem you know like
like any form of ancient art you know
like a like a poem that has form
anything that has a a basic structure
which we can all agree upon and which
brings us together which makes us know
that I am I am part of this culture
rather than this other culture like I
I'm somewhere in the world I'm part of a
group I'm part of a communion of people
so I participate in the language of the
church but then I'm also participating
in the community of the church because I
am making objects for specific uses I am
making an object for someone who wants
an icon of their patron saint I am
making an object for a church who is
looking for a specific icon that they
want to have out there I'm making a
blessing cross so that the priest can
bless can bless the people and so the
object that I'm making is connected to
the community but at the same time what
is what's amazing about the luck that we
have making liturgical art is that the
subject of my art reaches as high talks
about mysteries that are as esoteric as
as a
is powerful as hidden as any
contemporary artist would ever be able
to touch right and so it's not just that
I'm the Terkel art is not just that I'm
there's a nobility in making a chair and
there's a there's a beautiful nobility
making a chair but when you're making an
object which also participates in the in
this this language of narrative of the
church then you're you're also dealing
with so you're connecting these stories
these principles and you're connecting
them with actual objects that are then
going to participate in the world I
always say that liturgical art reaches
higher than contemporary art and it
reaches lower than contemporary art
because it connects the it connects
actual used objects with these higher
principles and so that's why I think
that liturgical art is the only solution
for the cultural problem now I'm not I
think I just want it to be careful I I
was a bit hard on cultural
manifestations let's say modern cultural
manifestations I don't see that there's
anything wrong with movies or with
popular music in itself I mean obviously
a lot of it is trash but not necessarily
not necessarily it doesn't have to be
right and and novels or poetry all those
things are fine the problem is the
proportion it's that it's always a
problem of hierarchy everything has a
place the problem is when you you you
you things are not in their right place
is when there's a problem when we live
for entertainment that's a problem right
but it's okay you'd have a party right
it's okay to dance it's okay to to to to
have a carnival like traditional
carnivals are in every single culture
the problem is is proportion so for
example I think that in the in the
recovery of liturgical art in the
recovery of the biblical stories in the
recovery of the story of the saints in
the participation on in those stories
what we will also gain
is a amazing matrix of references the
matrix of references that built Western
civilization the matrix of references
that made Shakespeare what Shakespeare
was as we lose those we also lose the
profundity of the art just becomes this
vapid nonsense because we've lost all
these connecting threads that are that
come from the that come from the Bible
and come from our existence in this
liturgical liturgical world and so I I
do believe that to enter into let's say
to rediscover the liturgical I'll give
you an example like something especially
that a lot of people know Jordan
Peterson he's here he's he's a friend of
mine and he is working to help people
rediscover the biblical stories and I
think that that's awesome
because he sees that he sees the problem
I'm saying he says these biblical
stories are underlying our culture if we
take them out and we fall in vapid nests
and our you know our culture will be
nothing our morality will be nothing so
it's like let's rediscover those stories
but I think it's not enough I think it's
not enough to just know the stories I
think you have to jump in you have to
participate you have to enter into the
story and the liturgical life and the
liturgical year and and the liturgical
experience that is the that is the best
and most complete way to actually
participate and not just read the
stories as an intellectual exercise
let's say but like I said I do think
that once we have rediscovered once we
have entered in I don't have a problem
with other art coming out and I've seen
now several Orthodox artists and some
Catholic artists also who are who are
starting to use the I mean you see that
in Tokyo you see that in CS Lewis where
they are there they are bathing in
biblical understanding bathing in
traditional let's say structure
traditional narratives and they're
writing things which are not directly
liturgical which are not directly even
in tokens cases not even Christian on
the surface but is so understood from
underneath is so it's so bathing in
the-the-the all those references that it
creates a powerful story so I like I
right now I am working on a graphic
novel with a with an artist I wrote the
story with my brother and it's going to
be a wild very hopefully very
entertaining retelling of the legend of
st. Christopher and it's going to be
it's going to be an adventure with with
can anybody recognize that who do you
think is on the pillar maybe can you see
the pillar in the background yeah so st.
Simeon is in the story and so and so
it's if there's going to be dragons that
there's going to be monsters and all of
that but the underlying references the
underlying mesh of relationships is
going to come straight out of my own
experience in iconography in my own
experience in reading the lives of the
saints and and the Bible but I don't it
won't be for Christians I mean it can be
for Christians but I'm not writing it
for Christian I'm writing it for
everybody it's gonna it's not it's not
going to be this you know like you know
those Christian movies know those yeah
those are really really really bad and
they're and they're very bad because
they're because they don't have this
depth of understanding the relationship
between the visual world and the
narrative world and the patterns and the
rhythm they don't understand it they
just have this message that they want to
get across and it stinks it's it's it's
that literally like it stinks in the
sense that you can smell Oh
propaganda it's not it doesn't smell
good doesn't smell good but but III and
also even the silliness like even the
silliness is not totally absent from
this structure right the the
in the Middle Ages they had what was
called marginalia who knows what
marginality is so the way that medieval
manuscripts in the West were written is
that they would write the text in the
middle and then on the sides they get
wild and crazy
all right and so alright these are on
the side and it goes very very far so I
I have to apologize in advance
everybody everybody probably here has
seen the the search for the Holy Grail
by Monty Python right so who remembers
that trumpet ears at the beginning right
the the special trumpet ears right and
you think you think you'd say oh this is
this is right this is blasphemous right
this is this is a mocking Christianity
but they didn't make this up Monty
Python didn't make this up this is from
medieval manuscripts this is in the
Middle Ages they had but trumpets -
right and so there is room for the
margins there's room for the gargoyles
on the outside of the church there's
room for the carnivals you know the the
Mardi Gras is the carnivals all those
are part of the total story but we don't
live here of just four so father's even
can stop just move to something more
glorious here so that it's part of the
story the problem is that we don't we
don't live in Mardi Gras all right now
the whole year is Mardi Gras and now the
entire world is upside down and so
there's room for the upside down you
just keep it on the edges and then it's
it serves its purpose you know the Jews
they celebrate Purim every year and they
get drunk and they spin and they fall on
the ground and they dress they take they
cross dress they do all this stuff but
it's just one day year right just one
day a year and it's on the edge right
it's the last in that book where God's
not mentioned right so so hopefully I
hope that that this does help you
understand why I why I think that that
one of the reasons why a lot of us that
are now entering into liturgical art
we're doing it obviously for our own
sake for our own salvation I think and
because of because of our love of God or
love of the church and our love of this
art but I think we also
no at least I think that I'm also doing
this this is the only door this is the
only door that right now that can lead
to something productive because all the
others are out on the edges of the wheel
and so I don't want to I don't want to
fall off so all right thank you very
much
[Applause]